This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English, I'm Neil.
And I'm Sam, still working from home, as you can hear.
But for many, the return to the office has begun.
And to make things safe, new thermal cameras are being installed in some workplaces,
they measure body temperature to screen for coronavirus.
After weeks of working at home, the return to the office is slowly getting underway in a number of
countries. But workplaces are having to change in this coronavirus era.
Lots of companies are rushing to install technology to make offices and workplaces safer.
Sensors that monitor our movements, smartphone apps that alert us if we get too close to workmates,
and even devices that take our temperature could all become the new normal.
That's a phrase we hear a lot these days, meaning a previously unfamiliar situation that has
become usual and expected. In this programme, we'll take a look at how this technology works,
and ask if it really is the answer we're looking for.
But first, today's quiz question. The thermal cameras I mentioned screen for coronavirus
by recording skin temperature in the area of the body, which most closely resembles the
internal body temperature. But which area is that? Is it A, the I, B, the ear, or see the nose?
I'll say A, the I.
Okay, Sam. We'll find out later if you were right.
Now, as employees slowly return to work, tech companies are busy finding ways for them to do so
safely. One such company, MicroShare, is managed by Charles Pomell. He spoke to the BBC World
Service programme TechTent to explain a possible solution.
So the technology that we are offering is using Bluetooth wristbands or tags that people are
wearing within the workplace, which detects proximity events. When the proximity event has been
recorded, it's been saved by the company in case they need to further down the line, retrace the
steps of a certain person who has been declared as infected and inform anyone else they may have
been in contact with. One important way to control coronavirus involves contact tracing. This means
that someone who tests positive for the disease informs everyone else they've been in contact with.
MicroShare's system for this uses Bluetooth. Technology that allows computers, mobile phones and
other devices to communicate with each other without being connected by wires.
Employees wear Bluetooth wristbands, which register when workers come into close proximity.
How nearer person is to another person. Anyone who has been close to a workmate will then know
they have to take action if that person is found to have coronavirus later down the line in the future.
Wearing wristbands, monitoring data on smartphones and being recorded by cameras,
it all feels like quite a big invasion of privacy, doesn't it?
It certainly does. And although some argue that such measures are necessary in these unprecedented
times, others are worried about the possible consequences. Here's human rights lawyer Ravie
Nyke with a warning. From a human rights perspective, you have to try to ask, are you trying to use
tech for tech's sake? Is this actually going to facilitate an understanding of who is safe to go
back to work or not? And if not, what's the necessity of this? Because it's such a significant
interference with basic human rights, there has to be a high level of evidential justification
to deploy this type of technologies. And I just don't think it's there.
Ravie questions whether these devices will actually help identify who can return to work,
whether the technology is being used for its own sake. An expression meaning doing something
because it is interesting and enjoyable, not because you need to.
Ravie's work as a lawyer involves finding proof that something is right or wrong.
If people's human rights are being interfered with, he thinks there has to be evidential
justification. Explanation of the reasons why something is the right thing to do based on evidence.
Like the evidence from screening body temperature. Which brings us back to today's quiz question.
Remember I asked you which part of the body is scanned by thermal cameras to measure body temperature?
And I said A, the eye. And you were absolutely right.
There's a small area of the eye close to the tear ducts, which is the most accurate part of the
skin for measuring body temperature. Oh well there you go. We've been discussing how thermal
cameras and other workplace devices being used to prevent coronavirus are becoming the new normal,
a previously unfamiliar situation that is becoming normalized.
Some of these devices are wristbands with Bluetooth technology allowing computers and smartphones
to communicate remotely without wires. They can identify work colleagues who have been in close
proximity in other words near to each other. That will be helpful if one of them tests positive
for coronavirus further down the line at some point in the future.
The coronavirus pandemic has caused massive changes in workplaces around the world,
but some critics are concerned that contact tracing technology is being used for its own sake
because it's interesting and enjoyable to do rather than being absolutely necessary.
And since much of the new tech invades personal privacy, it should only be introduced with
evidential justification. Explanation of why it is the right thing to do based on evidence.
Unfortunately that's all we've got time for, but remember to join us again. Bye for now. Bye.